انت كنت البنايه سقطت وعشتي كل المشهد
وبقيتي تحت الانقاض صحيح ممكن تحكي لنا
القصه الحكايه من اللحظه الاولى كيف لما
بدا الزلزال
ولحين انا خرجت اول شيء كنا نايمين الصحه
ابنائي اعطيته الجوال شوي لانه ابني كان
مريض حسينا يعني بشاعه بيتحرك قلت معقول
انا فينا ضغط شوي قلت معقول ضغطي عم يلعب
فيا متسطحه هيك حسيت لانه قبل بمره صار
هزي انا كتير برتعب قلت لهم طلعت البنات
طلعت ابني ركض ركض طالعنا كان مطر كتير
كتير مطر صار فجاه ياخد من البيت هيك
ويجيبنا هيك ياخذنا هيك ويجيبنا هيك بعدها
صار مثل الجرس يلعب فينا هل صحيح كان في
صوت قوي صاحب الزلزال كان صوت كاني عم
السيخين حديد عم تضربن في بعض كاني عم جرس
المدرسه على شكل جرس المدرسه اول شيء صار
اخدنا هيك وجابنا هيك وبعدها صار يخضنا خط
البيت بس بدي اركض طالع الاولاد اول شيء
طلعنا مطر كلياتنا طلعنا فتت قلت اسا عم
نطلع نحنا وعم ينزل علينا هات أردي الرماد
ايه انا قويت قلبي لانه ابني مانو لابس
مشان ما يمرض لانه مريض
يعني ما توقعنا انه تنهدي علينا لهالدرجه
يعني قبل بمره
صارت وقالنا لهالدرجه خرجتي في البدايه
ومن ثم لتجني بملابس استمر الباب ما طلعت
اجيب الجاكيت طبت
انت وحدك
يعني انت انت الوحيده اللي كنت تحت
الانقاض كافيه كتير
طابق وانه راحوا وما في اتصالات وهنا
فكروني طلعت انا وانه بعدوا يعني موقف
كتير صعب يعني لهلا اقعد بصرخ بقول لهم
الارض عم بتهز الارض عم بتهز